MATT DUFTLER: Welcome
Cloud OnAir, live webinars
from Google Cloud.
We host these webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Matt Duftler.
And today, we'll be talking
about automated canary
analysis.
Joining me are Steven Kim from
Google, Michael Graff and Chris
Sanden from Netflix.
And they'll introduce themselves
as they come up to speak.
You can ask questions
anytime on the platform.
And we have Googlers on standby
to answer your questions.
So let's get started.
We're going to start
with a pretty high level
overview of CI/CD,
continuous integration
and continuous
delivery, then we'll
dive into exactly what
a canary release is.
We'll talk in a fair amount
of detail about Kayenta itself
and how it integrates
with Spinnaker,
then we'll do a demo.
Then Chris will come
back up, and he'll
talk about different
practical considerations
to keep in mind as
you start to employ
automated canary analysis in
your own release pipelines.
Then Steve will
come up, and he's
going to go through the
various steps of getting
Spinnaker installed, just
kind of a pathway to follow.
Install Spinnaker, enable
Kayenta, configure everything,
what kind of
metrics to look for,
where to find the various
community members involved.
And then we'll do some Q&A. So
get your questions in early,
and we'll tackle
as many as we can
at the end of the presentation.
So this is a fairly typical
development team's workflow.
You can see it's
rendered as a loop.
The idea is that developers
are always making changes.
They're always pushing changes.
The changes are
constantly integrated
into the main branch of a
shared source code repository.
All of those changes are
subjected to automated tests,
and ultimately, builds
are automatically
produced that can be released
into production at will.
You want to avoid
the scenario where
you plan releases over
a period of many months,
and it's a big risky operation.
The idea is to
automate everything
from I make a change in
my source code, I push it,
go through all the
various test suites,
automatically produce a
build, get it in a state
that it's ready to be deployed
into production at any time
with the push of a button.
We don't want this to
be a big risky thing.
It should be boring and
safe, and you should
be able to do this at any time.
Keep in mind when we
talk about releases
throughout this
presentation, we're
really talking about
any production change.
It can be a code change.
It can be a change
in the configuration
of the application.
It can even be changes to
the infrastructure underlying
the application itself.
With this in mind, the
primary goal of Spinnaker
is to make releases boring,
safe, and repeatable.
Canary releases are just one
tool in the Spinnaker toolbox
to make releases safer.
As you hear all of us
talk about canaries,
and we're going to show all
the different configurations,
and we may here and there
describe it as testing,
keep in mind it really
is not in any way
a replacement for
other forms of testing.
As you build out your release
workflow for your shop,
this is not a replacement
for unit testing, integration
testing, capacity and load
testing, or any other form
of automated tests.
It's just an additional
thing that you
can employ with the goal of
increasing your confidence
that a new release is
safe to fully deploy
into production without slowing
down your development workflow.
Next up, Chris is
going to come up,
and he's going to
describe exactly
what a canary release is.
CHRIS SANDEN: Great.
Thank you, Matt.
So to expand on this idea
of a canary release further,
it is really a deployment
pattern or release
process where a new change--
whether it's code, configuration
as Matt alluded to--
that it's deployed
into production
before a subset of our users.
And so it gets its
terminology or its name
from the coal mining
industry where
miners would take a canary bird
into the coal mine with them.
And these birds would act
as an early warning signal
to the buildup of toxic gases.
This would give the coal
miners a sense of safety
as they worked in the mine.
In a similar way,
a canary release
can help make a deployment
safer by reducing
the impact that any one change
can have on your environment.
And this is because
the canary as you
release it is going to serve a
small subset of your traffic.
If something catastrophic
happens or goes wrong,
it'll only impact a small
percentage of your users.
And so this can lead
to safer deployments
by reducing that blast radius.
Now, to emphasize
what Matt has said,
a canary release is
not a form of testing,
or is not to replace
testing in of itself.
It's just another tool
towards a safer deployment,
and augments or enhances
the CI/CD workflow.
Now, as part of
a canary release,
a decision does need
to be made regarding
the behavior of the canary.
If the behavior of this canary
or a release or a change
looks good, do we want to
take that and deploy it
to the rest of production
or to all of our users?
To help facilitate
this decision making,
we do need to collect
metrics that describe
the behavior of the system.
Now, these metrics do need to be
tagged or name spaced in a way
such that we can easily
retrieve them after the fact.
So you can think of
this as making sure
that when we report metrics and
report metrics independently
for the canary and for,
say, our production
service, so we can
visualize or do
some analysis later with them.
So once we have a set of metrics
that have been collected,
a decision is usually
made by looking
at graphs and dashboards
manually and trying to decide
does the canary look good?
And you can kind
of think this is
a game of spot the
differences, where you're
looking at the behavior of
the canary as determined
by the set of metrics in
relation to that production
system.
And you're really
trying to determine
if the behavior
of that canary is
significantly different
than the production system.
Then based on that
decision, you may
decide to deploy that change or
that canary to all your users
or to the rest of your
production environment.
However, this manual
process of looking
at graphs and dashboards
can be error prone.
It does require
subjective assessment
and is prone to human
bias and errors.
So I may look at a canary result
or the results of a canary
and decide it looks good.
But Matt may come along,
and based on his experience,
he may look at that
and say, things are OK.
Let's push to production.
So in addition, this
process of manually looking
at graphs and dashboard
is time consuming.
Having someone look at all
the graphs or results just
doesn't scale.
And as you move towards more
frequent and rapid deployments,
having someone there to
gate every deployment
is not so feasible.
And then finally, it can
be very difficult to assess
the quality of the
canary in relation
to the production's cluster
or the production deployment.
The canary is not serving
the same amount of traffic
or doing the same type of
workload as production.
And this makes it very
difficult to compare
the canary to production and get
a good sense of the behavior.
And to address these issues, we
can enhance the canary release
process in primarily two ways.
First, we can introduced an
independent baseline group
or server group as part of
the canary release process.
And so the baseline
here is going
to be running the same version
or configuration as production.
So in our diagram
here, it's going
to be running, say, version 1.
At the same time, we're going
to create the new canary
version as well.
And this is going
to be version 2.
Now, the baseline and canary
are going to both be, say,
one server or one
instance, and they're both
going to serve the exact
same amount of traffic.
So for example, if the canary
is serving 5% of our traffic
and is one server, our baseline
is also going to be one server
and serving 5% of our traffic.
Now, its important to
remember that these clusters
or these server
groups are going to be
serving a very small
percentage of our traffic.
And again, this is to
limit the blast radius
that any type of change
can have on our end users.
Now, once we have this
environment setup,
we can compare apples to apples.
We can now compare the canary
directly to the baseline
and make some type of
automated decision.
And this is where
Kayenta comes in.
Its a platform for doing
automated canary analysis.
So Michael will now come up and
talk a little bit about Kayenta
and how it integrates
with Spinnaker.
MICHAEL GRAFF: Thank you, Chris.
Kayenta is our open
source platform
to allow canary analysis to add
to a pipeline within Spinnaker.
Spinnaker is our open
source deployment platform
built jointly between
Netflix and Google.
These are all open sourced,
and we have a strong community
around Spinnaker already.
And we're intending to
build a strong community
around Kayenta, especially
around adding new judges
and new metric data sources.
Spinnaker's role is to
set up the canary such
that Kayenta can perform
judgments on that data.
For example, here
we have a baseline
which is running exactly
the same production
code or configuration
that the main production
system is running.
And the canary is
running the new change.
It could be a
configuration change,
or it could be a code change.
And Spinnaker will
call upon Kayenta one
or more times during
some time window
to perform judgments
on how healthy
that canary is in
relation to the other.
How traffic is actually
routed is somewhat application
specific.
One common example
which we'll show later
is a load balancer,
which is simply however
many instances are
available, each one
gets a certain
percentage of traffic.
But in some situations,
you may have
to choose a more
complicated approach
where you send 1% or some
small amount of traffic
to your canary and baseline.
This is a simplified
version of a pipeline.
In this case, we have
Spinnaker deploying
the canary and the baseline, and
then calling upon Kayenta one
or more times to get
the individual scores.
In this example, you
have three scores;
in this case, 90, 92, and 95.
Those could be in different
regions, different locations,
New York and California.
They could also be across
multiple time windows.
A very common scenario is to
deploy for a four-hour canary
and have 30 minute intervals.
So we wait a small period
to let things warm up,
and then every 30
minutes after that, we
perform a canary analysis.
Based upon the
result of that score,
Spinnaker will
decide whether or not
I should continue
deployment to production
or roll that back and
cancel the canary operation.
When Kayenta is actually
performing each analysis,
this is the following
steps it takes.
It will gather the metrics
from both the baseline
and the canary for each
metric that's defined
in the configuration file.
That's why it's important that
we can separate those out,
and they have to
be tagged properly
so we know is this
a canary metric,
or is this a baseline
or production metric?
We'll validate that we got
the data that we expected,
align the data together so
that the similar metrics
from baselining
and canary lineup.
We'll then performs
some cleaning,
make certain the data
is easy to compare,
compare each individual metric
as either a pass, a fail--
and a fail can be
either high or low.
And you can override
which direction
you're sensitive to, so you can
choose high is OK, low is OK.
And finally, an individual
score is computed.
And this individual score
is a snapshot in time.
This is what the canary
looked like at this moment.
When you do a four-hour
window in multiple canaries,
you expect each one
to pass, and there's
a lower threshold at
which will cancel,
and an upper threshold at
the end in which will accept.
So here to give a demo is Matt.
MATT DUFTLER: Thanks, Michael.
We'll just have to navigate to
the other tabs to do the demo.
We're going to do a live demo.
So fingers crossed.
All right.
So just to give you an idea
of what you're going to see,
we're going to start
with a quick high level
overview of Spinnaker.
We assume some
viewers potentially
haven't interacted with the
Spinnaker user interface
before, may not be
very familiar with it.
So we'll introduce some of
the more important topics.
And then we'll work
through the full process
from beginning to
end of defining
a canary configuration, figuring
out which metrics to use,
how to apply this to a
set of released pipelines,
we'll walk through
the configuration
of those pipelines, and then
we'll kick everything off
by pushing some changes which
we'll show in detail, and then
interact with the results, poke
around the reports and so on.
So what we're viewing
now is a clusters view.
Think of this as the operational
pane or operational view
of Spinnaker.
It shows all of the
various resources
we have under management.
In this case, we're
managing things
deployed through Kubernetes.
So represented on screen now
are four individual deployments
spread across two name spaces
of production and a staging name
space.
And this is a sample
application just
for the purposes of this demo.
There's a frontend component,
a backend component,
and they constitute a very
simple web application.
The details of it,
it's written in Go,
but they're not
that significant.
But the important
thing to keep in mind
here, there are
four deployments,
they're already running.
Some in production,
some in staging,
it's a pair of frontend,
backend in each.
So one thing to note
as we look here,
I've highlighted
this deployment.
You can see the details in the
view on the right hand side.
And you can see each of
these little individual green
chiclets.
These represent pods.
And this is the most important
thing to note at the moment
where it says V14.
This is associated with the
14th revision of that deployment
within Kubernetes.
We have the revision
history set to 0,
so you won't see the older ones.
As they're scaled down to
0, they will be destroyed.
But the idea is to keep
in mind that revision,
because as we work through
the release process,
you'll see that revision
is going to roll forward
and 15 will show up.
So this is the operational view.
The pipeline configuration
is the automation view,
which we're going to
come to in a moment.
And remember, our
goal here is we're
going to configure
a way to experiment
with pre-configured
pipelines that
use the automated
canary analysis service.
So before we configure the
automated canary analysis
stage within any
pipelines, we need
to have some canary
configurations available.
So that's the next view that
we're going to experiment with.
So I believe Chris touched
on this or will in a moment.
One of the ideas is to
co-locate the configurations
for the automated
canary analysis
runs with the
applications themselves.
This is tweakable.
You can have it so that
your canary configurations
can be used across
all applications
or are scoped to a
set of applications.
But the primary goal is that
the operators of these systems
want to have their
canary configurations
close by to the services
and applications
that they're using those canary
analysis configurations with.
So there's a full user
interface with capabilities
for editing these things
and managing them over time.
They're all persisted along
with the other artifacts
of Spinnaker.
So in this case, we're
deploying to Kubernetes,
and we're using Stackdriver
to monitor those resources.
I would consider
it a prerequisite
of using any of this
that all of your systems
are properly instrumented.
So if you're not instrumenting
your applications
and your infrastructure,
there's no way
you'll be able to select
appropriate metrics later
on for use in canary analysis.
In this case, we selected
three very simple metrics.
You can see them down below.
We'll just show the
configuration of one of them.
So we're looking
at the CPU request
utilization for containers.
Again, it's on Kubernetes.
We give it a name.
We're using this thing we
call a custom filter template.
And the idea here
is that you can
use some of the out of
the box capabilities
for building the queries,
or you can customize it
any way you like.
It really depends
on your use case.
The most important thing touches
on something that Michael said,
which is that you must know,
in order to use this system,
how to segment your data.
If you can't clearly identify
which data was collected
or which metrics were
collected from your baseline
and which metrics were
collected from your canary,
you won't be able
to run the analysis
and compare the aggregated
results of each.
So we have this
canary configuration.
It has a name.
And now, we're going to
go over the pipeline view.
And we're going to interact
with the pipeline configuration
and select this canary config
for use as part of a rollout.
OK.
So this is a fairly
typical setup.
There are three pipelines.
First one is deploy
to staging, then
we have deploy with
automated canary analysis,
and then promote
canary to production.
The goal of the
first pipeline is
to be triggered
whenever any push that's
relevant to this
deployment is picked up.
So that can be a change to one
of the underlying containers.
That could be a
change to a manifest.
In this particular case,
we've configured this pipeline
to kick off whenever frontend
or backend container images are
changed, or when either of
the manifests associated
with those deployments
are changed.
We won't go step-by-step
through the configuration,
but it's important
to know that's how
it's kicked off because
we're going to push a change.
And it makes sense to know
where that's coming from.
So if we look deeper
into the pipeline,
we then see two
parallel deployments.
It's going to deploy frontend
and backend, but each of them
are going to staging.
At this point, we're
not doing any canarying.
The goal here is to show how
we integrate a canary release
into this process.
So we deploy frontend
and backend to staging.
We run some simple
acceptance tests
over the backend,
which in this case,
really amounts to
Kubernetes job,
running a cURL command against
the internal backend service
in whichever name space
it's in, which in this case,
will be staging.
And lastly, a manual judgment.
And all that manual judgment
is for is, in this case,
a human to say, I'm happy with
how it worked out in staging.
I'm ready to promote
it into production.
So I'm going to kick
this off, and then we'll
come back and look the
other configurations.
So what we've done here is
make a very simple change
to the manifest that backs
the backend deployment.
We've dramatically restricted
the resource allocation for CPU
for the backend so that when
we collect the metrics for CPU
utilization, it should go
up quite a bit from baseline
to canary.
So it has 1/20 of the
allocation of the baseline.
So we'll push this change.
And all this change is doing,
really, this operation,
is just pushing that updated
manifest to a storage bucket.
In this case, it's GCS.
And this pipeline is configured
to listen for pubsub events.
So we see it already kicked off
an instance of that workflow.
We would expect the frontend
to complete quite quickly.
Kubernetes is smart enough
to detect if it's really
a no op push,
which in this case,
we didn't change the frontend.
It'll complete quicker
than the back end.
All right?
So the backend
will take a moment.
It is updating that manifest,
so we should see this--
obviously, that revision
should roll forward.
And there's the new one, 15.
And then you'll see 14 will
slowly go away over time.
If we had left the
revision history set
to anything higher than
0 for that deployment,
you would see the old
revision would remain even
though it would have 0 pods.
In this case, it will
go away over time.
So we let that carry
on with its work.
We'll go back to
the pipelines view.
It's deploying.
It'll take a moment.
And what's going
to happen next--
I'll show you the
configuration while we wait.
Actually, it's going
pretty quickly.
So [? with ?] the next
pipeline is deployed
with automated canary analysis.
This pipeline is not configured
to listen for changes
to the manifests or
the container images.
Its configuration just has
it listening for pipeline
to complete successfully.
And it's set to deploy
the staging pipeline.
It will inherit all of
the artifact information.
So it'll know what
images were deployed,
it'll will know what
manifests were deployed,
and it can use all that
information in its execution.
But it's not listening
for changes to them.
It only waits for that
parent pipeline to complete.
And then what it
does is, again, we
see this parallel deploy scheme.
It's going to, again, deploy
those images and manifests
that are under test,
frontend and backend.
Only in this case, instead
of deploying the staging,
it's going to deploy
into production,
then it's going to run
the canary analysis.
So let's just OK
this manual judgment,
and then we will carry on with
looking at that configuration.
So we'll give that a moment.
While that's thinking, let's
look at our cluster setup.
So remember for the next step
that each of the existing
deployments have five pods.
Because as Chris and
Michael both touched on,
when you do your
canary, you want
to do it with a smaller
percentage of traffic.
This is a demo, it's
dramatically simplified.
We're not deploying
another baseline.
We're actually
comparing the canary
to the existing baseline,
which is not ideal.
You want to restrict
the amount of traffic
the canary takes though.
In this case, where we
have five existing pods,
we're going to end
up deploying canaries
that have one pod each.
It's going to end up taking 1/6
of the traffic, which is a bit,
but it's a demo.
So let's look at
the configuration.
It's doing the deployments now.
But let's look at this
canary analysis stage.
So it's pretty straightforward.
There are not an enormous
amount of configuration options
here at the moment.
But the most important
setting is right at the top.
And it lets you choose either
real time or retrospective.
If this were not a demo and we
weren't doing this cooking show
style, we would do real time.
The deployments would happen,
and then we would wait.
We would give it
a warm up period.
We would wait, let's
say, 20 minutes,
and then maybe do four canaries
over the course of two hours,
and each one would be a
30-minute canary analysis run.
So that would be real time.
But we're doing retrospective
because we don't want to wait.
Most of the settings
are the same,
except instead of waiting and
then breaking it into pieces,
you encode the time
stamps directly
within the canary
stage configuration.
So we're using some time stamps
from data we collected earlier
in the day.
Other than that,
it looks exactly
as the real time setup would.
So you see here we have location
for baseline and canary.
We just give the name
space for each of those.
And then you have
baseline and canary scope.
So the baseline, well,
we just want the primary.
As we said, it's just
the baseline deployment
for the backend component.
For canary, we want
backend canary.
In the case of
this configuration,
this is how we're
segmenting the data.
We're using a naming scheme
and some labels and things
like that.
This depends on your use case.
There are lots of
different ways to do this.
Especially with Kubernetes,
the most common case
is just to assign
labels that let
you identify where the
metrics were collected from.
So it's really use
case dependent.
This is just one path.
We say what it is
we're examining.
They're Kubernetes containers.
Then we get down to
these scoring thresholds.
I don't think we
touched on these
with the canary configuration.
But as you decide
which metrics you
want to query as part of
your canary configuration,
you can group them together
and then assign weights
to those groups.
And all of that is built up
into a resulting confidence
score for a given
canary analysis run.
But as a given run can
contain multiple intervals,
we allow you to specify this
threshold called marginal.
And where this is used is
that as each interval run is
completed, if your
confidence score is
below the marginal threshold,
it just pulls the plug.
It says, pull the rip cord.
We're going to punch out now.
We're not going to
do the future runs.
Don't pay the cost.
So long as all
those interval runs
are above the
marginal threshold,
it will carry on and do
all the future intervals.
Where the pass threshold is used
for the final confidence score.
So the score returned
from the final interval
of the canary analysis runs.
As long as it's above
pass, that canary stage
is considered a success.
If it's below, it's
considered a failure.
As with all Spinnaker
stages, there
are a host of configuration
options about what
to do in the case of a failure.
Do you halt the whole pipeline?
Just this branch?
Do you ignore it?
And so on.
So it's highly configurable.
All right.
So in this case,
it's hard to read,
I know, but we have a one-hour
duration between start time
and end time.
And we set the
interval to 30 minutes,
so it's going to result in
two canary analysis runs.
And we set to look
back type to growing.
And what this means
is that you'll
see a run with 30
minutes of data
and then a run with
60 minutes of data.
You could do sliding
as an alternative.
As we get into this-- and
we'll talk more about this
in a moment--
but the goal of
retrospective analysis,
while it's sweet
to use for demos,
the real goal is
to allow you later
on to do further
experimentation,
refine your canary
analysis setup,
and experiment with
different types of judging,
different metrics stores,
different precisions where
the metrics are
collecting, and so on.
So if we go back to
our view, while it
did the deployment here.
So remember, we said
here, yep, we're happy.
We want to deploy the
canary to production.
It does the deployment
of the front end
to production, the
back end, and then it
does the canary analysis runs.
And then you see it
did the two runs.
So you can see duration is 30
minutes, duration is one hour,
it'll show you the
time stamps here.
And there's this nifty
copy to clipboard thing
if you want to do
a retrospective
analysis using those values.
But really what we want
to get to is the report.
So if we click on this report--
and all of these
UIs are brand new.
It's something we're
really proud of.
Dan Peach on our
team here at Google
worked with a fellow
named Scott from Netflix
to build out all these
UIs from scratch,
including the configuration,
the reporting, all of it.
It's really great.
We're pretty pleased with it.
So you can see here, these
are the three metrics
we configured in that canary
config we looked at earlier.
And one of them is high.
The other two are pass.
We didn't do anything
fancy with the weights.
So you can see just
based on that confidence
score, obviously, it's
2/3 because two passed
and one failed, and they're
equally weighted by default.
But here, you can
see blue is canary,
baseline is this other color,
which I think is copper.
I'm not sure what color that is.
But you can see
the CP utilization
for that given metric
was obviously much higher
because we really constrained
the resource allocation for CPU
of that deployment.
So what we've seen here
besides the quick kind
of 15-second blast
of this is Spinnaker
is what the clusters
look like, which
are deployments because
we're on Kubernetes here,
how to navigate the
operational view of Spinnaker,
how to configure
your pipelines to use
the canary configurations
that you can curate directly
within the user interface.
Then we pushed a change,
which was a modified manifest.
We pushed to a GCS
bucket, pops up event,
triggered that first pipeline.
It did the deployments.
It did the simple test.
We said, yep, we're OK, pushed
the canaries into production.
It pushed the canaries.
It ran the analysis.
If you look at what
was pushed, see,
it's just pretty cool
in that if you look at--
well, look at the production
environment for backend.
There are five pods.
And then if you look at backend
canary, there's one pod.
That's how it's getting that
small amount of traffic.
And lastly, before I turn
it back over to Chris,
there is another
pipeline here that's
configured to run on
successful completion of deploy
with automated canary analysis.
And this is really the
promotion pipeline.
If this runs, all it
really does is provision
the new deployments, scale
them up to full capacity,
and destroy all the Canaries,
and do some cleanup.
One last thing.
That canary analysis
stage we showed
is quite simple and
right now focuses
exclusively on configuring
the analysis runs.
But we're in the
process of building out
full provisioning capabilities
within this stage itself.
So you can employ
the best practice
that Michael and
Chris described where
as part of your
canary analysis, you
provision a new
baseline, a new canary,
and you compare
apples to apples,
and then do all the
cleanup afterwards,
and there are all sorts of
options associated with that.
So that's in progress.
Now you've seen how to use this.
Next up is Chris.
And he's going to
give you some things
to keep in mind,
practical considerations
as you deploy this in
your own environment.
CHRIS SANDEN: Great.
Thank you very much, Matt.
So we have been using automated
canary analysis at Netflix
for well over four years
and realizing the benefits
of this style of deployment.
And over these years,
we have learned
many lessons about
canary analysis,
and a few of those we hope
to share with you here today.
Now, something I do
want to emphasize
is that canary analysis is a
very iterative process that
doesn't need to be refined
over time for, say, each
of your applications.
As your applications
evolve, you make changes,
you add new features, your
canary release process
and your configuration
that goes along
with it is also going to
change and evolve as well.
So for example,
let's say that you're
going to be using
some new hardware
or some new infrastructure
for your application.
This may also change
the metrics or the way
that you perform
a canary, and this
is going to need to be
iterated on as well.
Now, this is particularly
true about the metrics,
which are used to assess or
judge the canary as well.
And so we want to select
metrics that describe
the behavior of the system.
And this is important for the
success of automated canary
analysis.
Now, the power of
automated canary analysis
comes from, one, the setup
of the infrastructure,
so creating a baseline
of canary groups.
But it also comes
from those metrics
and how we analyze them.
And so picking those metrics
will take time to get right,
but it is a very important
step to realizing
the benefit of this
approach in gaining trust
in your deployments.
And so for example, if
your canary is always
showing differences as
compared to your production
cluster based on some set
of metrics you selected,
you may lose trust in
the system over time.
And it may lead to more
time for you to investigate
and will reduce your deployment
cadence and velocity.
Therefore, you will need to
refine these metrics over time
and to make them very
important to your application
and to your release
process in general.
And this is why as part
of our work with Kayenta,
we did integrate the
metric configuration
and the canary
configuration right
into Spinnaker alongside
with your applications.
And Matt had showed a little
bit of this in his demo.
Our goal was to make it as easy
as possible to find, update,
and manage those types of canary
configurations and metrics
definition.
For example, in this
screenshot we see here,
we have a set of metrics
which we are defining,
and they're in a, say, one
group called group 1 here.
And we want to make these reside
alongside the application.
In this case, it's just
an example called My App.
But we can say I have multiple
canary configurations here,
example config and test.
And we want to put
these right along
with the application to
make them easier to find,
but also to allow people to
come in and modify it and update
them along with the rest of
their continuous integration
or continuous
delivery pipelines.
Now, there are a
few best practices
that you can follow when
trying to select these metrics
for automated canary analysis.
And so for example,
sparse metrics,
which rarely report
any type of signals,
are not real good candidates
for canary analysis.
And this is because
of the low reporting
interval of these metrics.
It would be a little
hard to analyze.
Now, in contrast to this,
certain types of error metrics
make good candidate signals as
they are very clear indicators
of failure.
These metrics can be very easy
to analyze and reason about.
For example, if you're looking
at an increase in error
rates for an HTTP
server, then it
is a very clear
indication of failure
if your canary has a higher
rate of these types of errors.
And we can see that in the
graph on the right here.
And finally,
metrics which relate
to application configuration
may not be a good single
for canary analysis.
For example, let's
say that you're
looking at the max number
of configured threads
for your applications.
This is not necessarily going to
be a good indicator of failure
as in the face of a failure,
the canary baseline will most
likely show the same result.
And so these aren't contributing
anything to your canary
analysis and will
want to be removed or
tweaked for your analysis.
Now, in addition to picking
the right metrics, which
is very important,
there are also
some other practical
considerations to keep in mind
or think about as you
employ canary analysis.
For example, when an
application does start up,
it may throw more errors
or have higher utilization,
and this can be because of
caches failing, getting warm.
It can also be because
of garbage collection
or the application establishing
connections to, say,
downstreams or upstreams.
Now, these types
of startup effects
will skew the results
of canary analysis.
And for this reason,
you'll want to ignore
these types of startup effects
as part of your canary release.
And so within Spinnaker
and within Kayenta,
we allow you to configure
a warm-up period.
And for example, we can see
that we're, in this example,
setting a warm-up
period of 10 minutes.
In this example, we're
going to ignore the first 10
minutes of the metrics and
then perform the analysis.
This will give you a little bit
better confidence in your data
and into canary release process.
And finally, you'll
want to consider
how big to make your
canary deployment
or how much traffic your canary
release is going to take.
So in this example we have
here, our canary deployment
is going to be taking
25% of our traffic.
This example is the
traffic is routed
based on a load balancer.
So this means that
25% of our traffic
is at risk of this new change
or this canary we are releasing.
Now, this is
contrary to the idea
that a canary is
about reducing risk.
And so there are some
balances or trade offs
you'll have to make in terms
of how big to make the canary
or how small the
make the canary.
And so in this example here,
we may want to use a smaller
number of servers-- maybe
we use only one server
for the canary--
or find a different
way for our traffic
to make its way to the canary.
You can also debate, should we
even use a canary in this case?
Let's say that my application
is one instance or one server.
A canary may not
be the right tool
to use in this case to
mitigate that risk of a change.
So up next, Steven's
going to talk a little bit
how you can get started
with Spinnaker and Kayenta.
STEVEN KIM: Hi.
I'll point you in a couple
of directions by which you
can get started on your journey
to doing canary analysis based
rollouts on your project
or in your organizations.
First, you need to
install Spinnaker.
Down below on the screen,
there's spinnaker.io,
our website, /setup.
There are a number
of ways that you
can go to install Spinnaker
on various different platforms
in different configurations.
And there, you can get
all the information
you need to get
Spinnaker installed.
For those of you who have
already installed Spinnaker
and are running
Spinnaker, obviously, this
is a no op for you.
Second, you need
to enable Kayenta.
And once again, on
spinnaker.io/setup/canary,
you'll find detailed
instructions for setup
and guides for how you can get
Kayenta canary analysis set up
on your Spinnaker instance.
And third, aside from directly
Spinnaker or Kayenta related,
you need to ensure
that your applications
and your infrastructure
metrics are
being reported to
your metric store
so that Kayenta can
then act on those.
So after the base setups
are done on the top row,
on the bottom row is about
you starting on your journey
that Chris mentioned
of figuring out
what are the right metrics
for your particular situation
and that iterative refining and
ongoing process of improving
your canary signals.
So number one,
identifying the metrics
that are strong
indicators of safety
for your particular
application and infrastructure
among the set that you set
up on the previous step
of infrastructure application
metrics being collected.
And then finally,
configure your canaries.
And once again, as
Chris mentioned,
this is going to be an
iterative and continued process
for you to do so.
We're very proud of the
collaborative good work
that we've done here.
Thanks for joining us.
We want to invite
you to continue
to join us by joining in
on the community on Slack,
on join.spinnaker.io where
you can go to reach us
with any questions or for help.
There's plenty of
documentation, as I
mentioned, on our main
website, spinnaker.io.
And then, of course, we
also welcome contributors,
whether they are bug
fixes, small features,
or large things such as
adding an entire metric store.
Our project is open source, and
you can find our code on GitHub
at /spinnaker/kayenta.
So stay tuned for live Q&A next.
We'll be back in under a minute.
MATT DUFTLER: Welcome back.
All right.
We're going to do
some Q&A. So these are
questions from the audience.
And I'll lead off with
the first question.
"Is it possible to override the
results of the automated canary
analysis?
What if I need to deploy
even if the system thinks
the canary failed?"
Yeah.
So there are a couple
of answers to this.
Yep.
So it's pretty
straightforward to override
the result. Spinnaker itself,
nothing specific to Kayenta,
supports the ability to
have both conditional stages
and branch operations, and
you can use expressions
in those conditions.
So you can very
easily do one thing
if the analysis passed,
one if it failed,
and join those back up
in a manual judgment.
So that's fairly
straightforward to configure.
More importantly,
if you're noticing
that folks are overriding the
decision of the canary analysis
often, you might want to revisit
that actual configuration,
see if it needs to be
refined because it probably
is a signal that folks lack
trust in the canary analysis,
maybe it's the wrong metrics,
maybe it runs for too
short of a period of time.
There could be
some reason why you
need to actually
address the root cause
and not just override
the decision and move on.
All right.
I think we can both
do the next one.
So I'll read the question.
"What's next for Kayenta?
Could you give some details on
how the automatic optimization
process could work and why
we would want to do that?"
You want to lead off and then--
CHRIS SANDEN: Sure.
So--
MATT DUFTLER: --comment as well.
CHRIS SANDEN: So what's
next for Kayenta?
There's a few avenues
that we're exploring
for the future of
Kayenta that relates more
to the analysis side of things.
I'll let Matt talk
a little bit more
of the infrastructure and the
Spinnaker work after myself.
And so some of the work we're
doing for Kayenta and where
we want to expand
and move towards
is making our results a
little more practical.
So right now we see a lot of
sensitivity in our approach.
And some of the
metric classifications
or metric results we give are
not necessarily as practical
as our end users would like.
So we want to spend some
time to revisit, how do we
make our results a little
more practical for end users
to consume?
The idea is to reduce risk.
We also want to make these
results practical and something
that you can use to gain
safety in your deployments.
In addition, as described
through the demo
and throughout the
presentation, Kayenta
is very much a mini
batch or micro batch
system where over
some period of time,
we're performing little
batches of analysis over time.
We'd like to
investigate or move more
towards a continuous
evaluation approach where we're
continually evaluating over
an entire period of time,
say, every minute
generating a score.
This allows us potentially
to fail even faster.
So we look at a
canary deployment,
and we look at the
risk is the greatest
in the first hour, in
the first 30 minutes,
or the first 15 minutes.
And so finding those failures
or those issues faster
is very critical to this
system managing that risk.
And so we want to work at
failing faster and finding
those big differences and those
big, impactful changes sooner.
And this will help
mitigate the risk
to be able to roll your
deployments back faster.
MATT DUFTLER: Great.
Thanks.
OK.
In terms of what's
next for Kayenta,
I can give some information
on what's next for the project
itself.
We've made all this available.
It works quite well.
We're very happy with the
current state of things.
Now we'd really like
to focus on adoption,
making it easy for folks
to get up and running.
We have quite a bit
of documentation,
but we'd like more, obviously.
We want to build out code
labs, potentially a workshop.
And most importantly, we
want to grow the community.
We have support at the moment
for Stackdriver, Atlas,
Prometheus, and Datadog.
The Datadog support
was added by Armory.
We'd like to repeat
that process,
have other active participants
in the Spinnaker community
add support for
additional metric stores.
There's a pretty well-defined
path for adding support
for additional metric stores.
We have a development guide,
and we have very easy to follow
commits that
explain step-by-step
how to add support
for new systems,
or add new integrations.
And in addition, we built
Kayenta from scratch
to be easy to develop within.
So everything is exposed.
There are troubleshooting
endpoints.
Everything is swaggered.
It's pretty well documented.
So it's a pretty
straightforward process.
It's not trivial, but
it's definitely doable,
and it's quite straightforward.
CHRIS SANDEN: I
think what also is
next is more engagement
from the community
and getting everyone
else involved in it,
contributing, and also expanding
our documentation and our best
practices.
We want to be able to
bundle in best practices
with Kayenta, so
whether that includes
example configurations of
metrics or example pipelines.
Now, that's also in
terms of getting feedback
from you, the people out
there wanting to use it,
and iterating on that as well.
MATT DUFTLER: Yeah.
We had talked a couple of times
about maybe making it smarter
in terms of suggesting
optimizations
to canary configurations,
or even proposing
canary configurations.
When there was an issue
that a human responded to,
maybe human can come back
and say, for this release,
for this scope--
so these time boundaries
with these resources--
what sort of canary process
would have caught this,
would have sussed out that
there's a problem and said,
this is not a safe deployment?
So we think we can get
smarter about that over time
and really not leave
folks with blank screens
where they have to figure
out all this configuration
from scratch.
All right.
So the next question
is, "documentation
mentions real time and
retrospective evaluation.
Can you give some pointers
regarding which to use when?"
All right, I'll lead
off, and you can jump in
if you want to add something.
So real time, we
touched on it a bit.
The idea is as part
of a release pipeline,
you provision the
resources, and then
you want to compare
the metrics being
collected from those resources
you just provisioned.
So you would have
typically a warm-up period.
And then for both the
newly provisioned baseline
and production and
canary deployments,
you would compare those metrics
to one another in real time,
meaning the metrics collected
over the last hour, two hours,
three hours.
Retrospective is similar
for all of the configuration
with the exception of
the timing information.
Instead of saying, start now,
wait this period of time,
and then do these
intervals, it says,
for these given encoded
timestamps, do the analysis.
You can still do
it in intervals,
but it refers to
past points in time.
The benefit of this--
besides being much
easier to demo--
is that you can experiment
with different configurations.
So different judges,
different metric stores,
more precise, less precise data,
more metrics, less metrics,
and so on.
All right.
I think the next
one's probably yours.
CHRIS SANDEN: So, "can
you talk a little bit
about your experience with
optimizing canary analysis
for applications?
What would your top three
lessons, bits of advice be?"
Its a good question.
Much like the practical
considerations
is I think one of the
big lessons to take away
is that the metrics matter.
It is the signals you
put into the system
are going to be very
important to the success
of canary analysis.
Kind of idea of garbage
in, garbage out.
You give it bad metrics, you
potentially get bad results.
And so there is this time,
this iterative process
of taking your canary release
and iterating on those metrics
and finding the
right signals that
are going to be successful
for doing a canary analysis.
And kind of piggybacking
off that idea
of putting the right
metrics into the system
is making sure that your
infrastructure is set up
correctly.
And well, for
example, making sure
that that baseline
and that canary
are both running in the
production in the same region
taking the same
amount of traffic.
The experimental setup or
the infrastructure setup
is very crucial to making
canary analysis a success.
And so having that
combination of a good setup
and a good experiment set
up, the right metrics, really
alleviates a lot of the issues
with downstream canary analysis
with why did this fail or
why did I see a difference?
So focusing on kind of
the setup and the metrics
can alleviate a lot of those
problems down the road.
MATT DUFTLER: Yeah.
This is a really great point.
If you can't [? absent ?]
Spinnaker and Kayenta,
clearly identify
how to segment--
along what dimension
to segment the metrics
that you've collected--
you won't be
able to perform the analysis.
Kayenta isn't going
to magically discern
the difference between
metrics you've collected.
You have to be able
to collect them,
identify the two
groups of metrics
that you've collected
that you want to compare.
That's what the
judge considers when
it's performing its analysis.
So that's a great point.
CHRIS SANDEN: So with that,
I think we're out of time.
MATT DUFTLER: Continue
to look for answers
your questions, folks.
We'll be answering those in the
setup after the webinar ends.
Thanks, everybody,
for your time.
Stay tuned for the next
session "Build Modern Apps
Using an API First Strategy."
[MUSIC PLAYING]